ce genre de nouvelles qu'un président
tient à annoncer lui même à bourg encore
au bugue d'arrêt the dead
dans notre hub confirme que le fondateur
du groupe armé état islamique
aboubaker al bagdadi est mort en échec
mais le président a décrit de manière
détaillée l'opération menée par les
états unis pour laquelle il a entre
autres souligné la collaboration des
kurde de la turquie et de la russie
mauvais c'était comme regarder un film
dit donald trump
une centaine de membres des forces
spéciales aurait traquer al baghdadi
dans les tunnels d'un complexe du
nord-ouest syrien
il aurait finalement déclenché la veste
explosive qu'il portait causant
également la mort de trois de ses
enfants
la nouvelle tombe à point pour le
président au cours des dernières
semaines il a dû défendre sa politique
au moyen orient
plusieurs de ses alliés ont critiqué sa
décision de retirer la majeure partie
des troupes américaines de syrie l'un
d'entre eux le sénateur lindsey graham
parle maintenant d'un changement majeur
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme avec
un jeune john winter précisant néanmoins
que la guerre contre le groupe armé état
islamique n'est pas encore terminée
c'est des gros organisation avec
beaucoup de dirigeants
cet expert souligne qu'il ya encore de
l'instabilité dans la région et que le
ton provocateur du président pourrait
même contribuer à envenimer la situation
la provocation les insultes personnelles
à l'endroit de l'état islamique ça vaut
tout simplement mettre de l'huile sur le
feu il faut comprendre qu'en partant
l'état islandais comme al qaîda ya huit
ans le désir de vengeance on est très
fort mais quand en plus le président
insultes l'organisation et ses membres
comme ça et c'est de la provocation qui
est qui et qui évoluent pas nécessaire
c'est contre-productif
si l'administration de shop se dit
consciente de la menace elle n'entend
pas changer sa stratégie au moyen-orient
ici rappelle bouvier oakley radio canada